it's the enticing new attraction pulling
tourists back to Thailand after several
years of covid-19 isolation
well not exactly new marijuana has
always been available but now Travelers
are flooding in to get a legal High
we used to have this in Thailand just
people would just go to a reggae bar and
just buy whatever they want in the
reggae bar and suddenly it's just like a
big trend for me it's good that it's
working tourists are probably coming
here more for the weed rather than to
come and experience Thailand properly
however I think it's great I think it
should be legal
with legislation in 2022 the Cannabis
Market exploded tourists and locals have
flocked to the newly licensed weed
retailers shops are popping up on almost
every busy street it's now a rooming
business they have been issuing the
license is about five thousand
for the shops right now in Thailand
which means like there are a lot of op
shops but not everyone is thrilled by
marijuana's new status some of the most
passionate advocates for legislation
have found their arguments trampled in
the Stampede to get into the market the
people that I've been fighting alongside
to have this legalized are not the one
benefiting
the one who are opening up shops every
other bloody day right now is not the
people that I knew I do not fight for
this so that there are Californian weed
on Bangkok streets and the law remains
unclear in many areas purchase and
possession in private is legal but
technically recreational use is still
against the law
for those who've been pushing the
benefits of medical marijuana the
original intention of the change in
legislation has been lost
foreign
before the tourists come to Thailand the
government should inform them that we
don't encourage recreational use but we
do encourage medical users and that they
can get services and advice from the
Thai traditional medicine clinics and
hospitals
legislation may become a Hot Topic ahead
of Elections later this year as many
conservative ties remain opposed to the
sale of drugs on their streets but with
the weird business now firmly part of
Thailand's economic Revival it could be
hard to uproot Tony Chang altazira
Bangkok